tick-tock has turned into a powerful
force for change in the music world and
not just by giving a new platform to
huge stars like megan the stallion and
little nazex it's also changing the way
aspiring artists launch careers and
allowing musicians to interact more with
their fans one such artist is 19 year
old sadie jean if you haven't heard of
her chances are the teenagers or
preteens in your house have why because
she is blowing up on ticktop using a
feature that gives others an opportunity
to create duets with her jamie yuka's
caught up with a college student to
discuss how her heartbreak tune became a
breakthrough hit
my time and i've been looking for love
online and maybe some of them my real
good guys they're never gonna be like
you though
everyone remembers their first
heartbreak
but sadie jeans became a viral sensation
when she shared it on tick tock in
what's called an open burst challenge i
think we could work it out
so what are you doing now sadie starts
the chorus then leaves a gap for other
artists to collaborate it blew up
[Music]
why do
[Music]
does it seem like a dream yes it's also
crazy because i've been waiting to put
out a song like my whole life i wanted
the first one to do well and so i waited
and i waited i waited i love when people
your age like 19 say i've waited my
whole life for this moment
[Music]
you think about love and heartbreak and
i got a lot of that on you
like where do you think the connection
point is for people even my age and
older to love this song so what are you
doing now is about wanting to reconnect
with a past love missing something and
like wanting to open that door again i
think everyone can kind of relate to
that in some sense her tick tock has
been viewed more than 500 million times
and some 400 000 videos have been
created with sadie's song
even grammy-nominated rapper lil yachty
couldn't resist
all of our memories
i'll see comments on my tick tock of
like i'm married for 25 years and this
song like makes me want to text my ex
what
like i'm sorry
tic toc's duet feature is a way for
artists to support one another while
expanding their fan base at the same
time they say that high school never
ends and i guess that's true you're
still in my head anson sayabra and katie
turner each contributed verses it's so
smart because like the original content
was already viral and then every person
who makes a response
has that piece of viral content in it so
any way you can get people to care about
you is the most valuable thing in the
world a fear of uncertainty has led me
to cope with astrology
it's a way to get people engaged on
tick-tock yeah it's a cool way of
marketing where you know it's to push a
song but it's doing it in such a way
that you feel included
[Music]
yes
sadie's tick-tock success landed her a
record deal i think there's no question
that tick-tock has completely rewired
the music industry in the last few years
rolling stone senior music reporter
elias light says tick-tock's worldwide
reach of more than one billion active
monthly users has made it a launch pad
for artists if you have a viral hit when
the record labels want to sign you you
get to ask for much better terms because
you already have created a lot of
momentum on your own
sadie's first west coast concert became
a sold out sing-along
[Music]
yet she still sees herself as a typical
teenager a bit shy and a little awkward
chasing her dream that began as a
toddler i would make my mom turn off the
radio and i would do like sadie's radio
and i would just make up songs i
remember like a few times making my
sister write them down for me because i
didn't know how to write yet
sadie has kept a collection of her songs
she wrote this around the age of 11.
you've been killing me inside for the
past five years of my life
so you were five or six years old that's
so funny
[Music]
sadie is working on new music and like
her idols jody mitchell carol king and
taylor swift sadie is not afraid to sing
about love gone wrong i just love the
drama it's just so much more satisfying
for me to write some valid wrench to the
heart song than anything else are you
nervous i'm not
i'm not nervous but maybe maybe they
should be nervous oh
she's warning everybody because i'm not
going to stop writing songs about
what i'm going through and sadie jean is
hoping what are you doing now turns into
this is what i'm doing later
cbs morning's jamie yucas los angeles
go sadie jesus
is genius they're really doing yeah
these duets that they do on tick tock
are absolutely amazing but i love when
she's talking about a lost love because
in high school nate when your heart is
broken you think i'm never going to fall
in love again yeah you realize that's
back you'll be all right it's not
official i'm going to say you're going
to be all right you have to trust us on
that